i want you to follow her and make sure
she doesn't betray us and uh don't tell
peralta count me in i got nothing else
going on aren't you supposed to be
getting ready to transfer to staten
island ah that's not real it's pretty
real last week that's before i decided
to pretend it wasn't
i'm in denial most people who were in
denial don't usually say they're in
denial that's because they're in denial
about being in denial but i'm not in
denial i'm in denial is jefford's brain
okay for this mission yes sir for this
and all future nine-nine missions which
i'll definitely be a part of let's go
[Music]
since we got time you want to talk about
your goodbye party will you eat a cake
or does it have to be boneless chicken
breast sure 70 year old terry can eat
whatever he wants you are talking about
my retirement party right 20 years from
now dude you know i'm not talking about
that what do you think is gonna happen
at the end of the week i don't know but
i do know what's gonna happen right now
topic change you ever wonder where wind
starts i have wind is crazy you need to
face facts about when i'm trying but you
won't engage why are you in denial about
when rosie man we are always getting
into the craziest situations if i were
leaving this squad i'd miss these
moments but i'm not so i won't okay
seriously what's going on with that it's
the whole thing is it gonna screw up the
plan it's more quietly self-destructive
sounds good terry do you could i have
everyone's attention i know it's my last
day and i've been in denial about it all
week
and i still am so i'm giving this toast
for no reason here's to nothing you okay
there terry it's just that if i wasn't
in denial
i would be so depressed right now at the
thought of leaving all of you i'm
telling you this machine is broken ask
me a question
is jay-z really your favorite artist yes
obviously lie
see it's busted is it or is your
favorite artist really taylor swift
no
lie
all right fine she is
she makes me feel things she makes all
of us feel things
look
that machine is working just fine why
are you being so crazy about this case i
wanted to work the toughest case we had
why because it would feel awesome to
solve it because a real man doesn't run
from a challenge i mean do they run from
the bulls in pamplona yeah
that's the whole point of it seriously
that seems lame i don't know why you
want to spend the entire weekend at work
but i'm going home to my family see you
tomorrow jake
fine abandon me i don't want you here
anyway
that's a lie come on man
[Music]
i'll pay for that
traffic is shut down civilians are being
funneled into checkpoints good i just
wish my guys over here could be a little
more efficient yeah i'm looking at you
detective fuzzy paws this is amy hates
dogs amy or amy extra stress amy it's
both amy's i'm under a lot of pressure
and also that dog is a piece of trash
okay until something else is going on
you don't have to pretend to be mad at
the dog first of all i'm not pretending
that dog sucks i am offended i am angry
i am very tired so i'm gonna take a nap
but when i wake up ugh
you are in for it
hey fuzzy paws i'm paying you to work
not lick your butthole i'm a terrible
captain stop that you are not a terrible
captain santiago face facts i'm garbage
no
this is about me and my issues with
authority you've been great wrong i've
been a disaster i can't believe you
would blame yourself for this how stupid
are you so stupid i'm such a stupid head
the fact that you think this has
anything to do with you is insane do you
even oh my god i'm yelling at you yes
you are you're in the zone keep going oh
okay
i can't believe you lost my pen that was
careless and rude and and it was a real
jerk move santiago you did it and i am
so sick of you playing your damn
classical music in your office all day
it's too loud we can all hear it okay
well this is you shut your mouth when
i'm talking to you santiago right too
far i'm sorry this is all very new for
me this is taking too long
i'm gonna miss the farmer's market you
know that's not a nice car right
say that again
damn cat be cool say that again
hey so you doing okay
not really i waited outside that
restaurant for two hours and he never
came out cantaloupe i'm good amy also
good all so good
[Music]
i want you on this text chain i really
do but since you joined yesterday you
have sent 71 texts the rest of the group
collectively has sent two you know
honestly i'd rather get hit by a bus
then get one more text from you charles
fine i've been kicked out of things
before at camp i found a slam book that
the lunch ladies had written about me
i'm sorry charles but there is no story
sad enough to save you now challenge
accepted
once as a tween i got my penis and okay
stop no no no our plan was just to teach
you to text better
you know a lot of people like the way i
text look if you can't accept me for who
i am then i don't need this chain okay
great i don't know i need to be included
so badly i'll do whatever you say i
literally have zero
[Music]
ever since we've been down here you've
been a little
depressed
have i
no
don't eat the burrito
what are you doing i'm just sealing
jason's collar in an airtight bag so it
retains his scent
i don't know how many whiffs i have left
wow
look i know that dog meant a lot to you
so i got you this
it's a dog
his name's arlo but you can call him
jason too or whatever seriously i can't
just replace jason with some other dog
why not all dogs are basically the same
watch this arlo go hump that toy
get away from that
that's jason's
look man
i've been patient but we have a case we
need to work on it's time for you to get
over it move on move on
move on
jason was part of my family rosa i loved
him his humping was the only thing that
got me through my divorce seeing him so
happy made me believe that i could be
happy one day too
you wouldn't understand this because you
have a motorcycle helmet for a heart but
i need to feel this sadness so the only
thing that i'm moving on from is you
so i like have a dog now
i'm sorry
oh
rosa crying
don't know what to do
pat pat this feels wrong i'm gonna go
cry in the bathroom peace out homies
this place is so romantic yeah and so
intimate don't worry i'm not listening
to you i'm just thinking about how this
sea bass is cold but not as cold and
cruel as the hands of fate that have
thrust my entire life
into darkness
ah damn it i just ordered the sea bass
oh babe this is so nice there are hot
stones on our butts for no reason not on
mine my butt stones keep falling off
cause i'm so tense about halt being here
and ruining everything it hasn't been
that bad really
oops sorry
can't even float right
just push me away
everyone else does it's not great but as
long as we stay in here we're safe we're
all to santiago i'm in your room what
how patio door was open i pushed through
the hedge tell me what is it about me
that screams loser yeah you know we're
kind of in the middle of getting
massages right now sir oh how
thoughtless of me i'll get down here so
you can see my face oh no
hello the question was what is it about
me that screams
loser
[Music]
i want to apologize for yesterday
inserting myself into my employee's
breakup with my nephew somehow
uh backfired that's nerdfall i'm the one
that made us seem like a dumb crying
baby
i'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the end of the
world to feel
things i guess not
it's up there
the thing is i really cared about marcus
but he wanted to get married and
i'm just not ready for that and if i'm
not ready with a guy as great as marcus
then
what if i'm never ready what if that was
it my one chance of love
and what if i never get a second chance
i don't know
i'm just
i'm just sad
well i i understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this
you